قتلى وخسائر كبيره بعد اطلاق صواريخ على
مدن عده في اوكرانيا السلطات اوكرانيه
تقول ان روسيا استخدمت كل انواع السلاح في
تصعيد
جديد صحيح نحن هنا في العاصمه كيف حقيقه
يعني تعرضنا لنوع منلع ل ان صافرات
الانذار يعني دوت في ساعات متتاليه وطويله
وصل عدد الضحايا حتى الان تجاوز 17 شخص
للاسف اغلبهم في العاصمه كيف ومدينه
خاركوف ونبر و زبروجيا واوديسا نحن نتكلم
عن هجوم شمل شمال وجنوب اوكرانيا شرق
وغربها فمدينه الفيب في الغرب اوديسا في
الجنوب سومي وخاركوف في الشرق وكيف في
الوسط كل هذه المدن تعرضت لهجمات للاسف
اغلب الاهداف التي
يعني استهدفت او التي وقعت عليها الشرايا
هي مباني سكنيه وتجاريه وفي دبرو على سبيل
المثال مركز للولاده هنا على بعد اقل من
اث كيلومتر منطقه الجيان سكيا سقطت شضايا
على مبنى تجاري وهذا المبنى وما حوله يعني
هو مجرد مباني سكنيه ومركز طبي اضافه الى
وهذه الصوره الان تظهر على شاشتكم في
منطقه اللوجان فسكي هذه البنايه تعرضت
اكثر من مره لتاثير لشظايا القصف ويقابلها
محطه مترو لوجيان فسكا التي في وقت اندلاع
او يعني حدوث صافرات الانذار يهرع
المواطنين للمكان المجاور لها والمقابل
وهو محطه مترو لوجيان فسكيه لانها ستصبح
ملجا نتامل حقيقه الا تستمر حده التصعيدات
خاصه مع السنه الجديده وان يكون هناك افق
لايجاد تسويه دائمه كامله تحقق تسويه
عادله بين الجانبين وتحفظ السلم والامن
العالمي والا العالم والمنطقه واوكرانيا
وروسيا مقبل على مزيد من التصعيد للاسف
الشديد في نهايه هذا الشتاء سيد عماد ابو
الرب رئيس المركز الاوكراني للتواصل
والحوار كنت معنا من كياف شكرا لك على كل
هذه المعلومات